un cultivo de bacterias en una caja de
petri se multiplica a un ritmo muy
rápido la relación entre el tiempo
transcurrido t en minutos y el número de
bacterias vedete en la caja de petri se
modela con la siguiente función y bueno
aquí tenemos modelo exponencial dice
cuántas bacterias habrá en el cultivo
después de 120 minutos redondea la
respuesta a la centésima más cercana si
es necesario y bueno esencialmente lo
que nos están pidiendo es saber cuántas
bacterias va a haber después de 120
minutos o dicho otra manera lo que
estamos buscando es ver
de 120 y bueno esto va a ser igual a
quien a 10
a 10 que multiplica a 2 elevado a la
potencia t pero te vale 120 minutos
entonces me quedarían 120 esto dividido
entre 2 y esto es lo mismo que 10 que
multiplica a 2 elevado a la décima
potencia y bueno 2 elevado a la décima
potencia es lo mismo que 1024 así que me
quedaría 10 que multiplican a 1024 y si
quieres comprobar que 2 elevado a la
décima potencia es 1024 lo podemos hacer
aquí 2 elevado a la quinta potencia
bueno eso es lo mismo que 24 8 16 32 32
y si multiplicamos 32 por 32 32 por 32
esto va a ser lo mismo que 2 por 32 64
bajo un cero y me queda 3 por 32 3 por
12 63 x 39 y sumamos me va a quedar
4 12 y llevamos unam y después 9 más
unas 10 mil 24 así que ya están 10 x
1024 es lo mismo que 10 24 10 10 mil 240
entonces abraham 10 mil 240 bacterias y
hemos acabado